HBO documentary films president Sheila
Nevins is considered one of the most
influential people in her feel like
meant you Sheila the award-winning gun
maker has produced more than 1,000
documentaries for HBO they include the
jinx Jim the James Foley's story and
when the levees broke her films have
touched on subjects like war child
beauty pageants Scientology and
Alzheimer's her productions have earned
her 26 thank you very much Academy
Awards after being behind the camera for
more than three decades Evans now has a
collection of short stories essays and
poetry it's called you don't look your
age and other fairy tales Sheila we
welcome you to the table thank you I
think this is one of my favorite
chapters it's called gliding gracefully
into gravity and you don't seem to be
gliding so gracefully into gravity you
talked very candidly about having a
facelift getting older isn't something
you're looking forward to yeah so so
like but it's better than the
alternative she'll in love with that I
didn't say it wasn't better than the old
I look at y'all stirred I'm
reupholstered well I I didn't say that I
hadn't glided no but you hated tired
well it is don't you like since we don't
think it's hard I don't know I think
when you look the way you do yellowing
worsen initial no I'm not okay look at
all the Rouge and look at all the stuff
I have on but in 56 you felt the need to
have a facelift I'm fascinated by that
56 was a long time ago why did I feel
compelled because I'm a superficial
person with deep feelings about
continuing to work and I didn't want to
give up it's harder for women than men
yeah I didn't want to walk into a room
and look like somebody's grandmother so
I submitted to the culture that told me
that Young was in is that bad of me no
no I don't know ank you bad no judgment
thank you no judgment no judgment oh
I'll be just a quick note the two of us
did a big conversation on my PBS show
the response was amazing to Charlie to
you so the point was how this message is
coming out of here yeah yeah is somehow
touching pieces very funny because women
have to lie about all they are they have
to pretend that's why we we do all the
horrible things we do to ourselves you
know we submit to surgery we and I'm
victim and a victor simultaneously I
mean I can fool you do I look my age of
course not
how could I it's like a couch that was
sitting in a long time it's comfortable
it's smart it's good can't get one like
it can't get me again so you might as
well be a pollster me you were want to
make most stunning sassy successful
women I know really you don't go out
much I love it but you know and just
because you know for people who don't
know Sheila Nevins then you've been
under a rock but I mean you have had the
most incredible documentary run at HBO
what have you learned about what makes a
good documentary the people that make a
good documentary I think that the people
say something they might not have said
to someone else right that they there's
a secret inside everybody and if you can
be sincerely interested in the answer
you can get the secret if your
artificial well you guys know that
better than I do but if you artificially
interested if you are reading off a call
card a card of some kind if you really
look that person in the eye and you say
you're really not afraid of Aging yeah
you really get an answer yeah and I'm
not taking my eyes off you but when you
first started with documentary Sheila
they said oh we'll give it to you
because nobody really watches it you
took that and ran with it
well I mean there was a method to your
madness and how you came up with your
documentaries by knocking it what's
going on in the real world yes for what
I mean
I think I got documentaries because they
were cheap and because they were fast to
make and I didn't really know I thought
a documentary was going to be Winston
Churchill the Second World War
Hitler and then I realized people were
not watching those doctors and other
people could do so I stole from movies
right so if jaws will you just had that
horrifying shark there if jaws was doing
well I did a documentary about sharks if
Bob and Ted and Carol and Alice was
doing well I did a documentary about
what it seems like now Sheila is that
documentaries are now looking at the
news sample yes we have all of a stone
doing a four-part documentary which
includes lots of interviews with
Vladimir Putin right Showtime right
what's the point is that you said you
know you were looking at what was what
was topical and not necessarily Putin is
as hot as anybody you can get at any
shark he's out there with those teeth
that is a great idea for popular
documentary documentaries are hot today
yeah they're hot
they really are hot yeah so yeah you're
you are ahead of yourself but I like it
I want to talk about your go back to
your book for a second is that really
important
did you get a free coffee or is it I got
gotten two free yeah I want to be a
success
Sheila she'll I want to are you are six
okay let me ask you let me just say
something that's about the one of the I
thought most poignant chapters was about
your mother because your mother was an
amputee yes you told the story about
eating at a restaurant
and her her stump was exposed and people
in the restaurant said hey cover that up
we're eating mm-hm and you got
embarrassed and apologized and left the
restaurant you got in the car and you
started crying because you thought I
should have spoken up and that's almost
like that was a jumping point for you to
speak up now you were embarrassing you
did not defend your mother you said it
was a long time ago I remember that I'm
embarrassed if I don't tell the truth
yeah as a result of that because I
apologize to this woman who said ladies
put that arm away and it was amputated
up to here and it was too heavy to put
under the counter and to didn't have an
elbow so it you know it was hard to rest
it and so it was like hanging yeah and
this woman was rude and I was
embarrassed about my mother and I I
don't want to be embarrassed ever again
for saying what's real I mean I'm not
embarrassed about truth I'm really not
you can talk to me about my face leaking
to other men any well maybe that's the
lesson of this book yeah be true to your
own self and be true in terms of your
relationship to the rest of the world
and also to aging
it is it just is there's less ahead than
behind have you used it behind well
enough I knew I could scare you well
that's how I don't like to think about
that yeah but the point is if you think
about it then you every moment becomes
much more precious to you because there
are a few moments so it's it's precious
to be here it's precious to tell the
truth it's precious to have someone come
over to you and say thank you for saying
that old it's hard you know thank you
for still working mm-hmm thank you thank
you thank you Sheila
he sings that hit oh my god the time I
just we thank you got you I look what
you got to read that if you're out there
one of the essays about ten rules of
advice for women in a male-dominated
workplace it's brilliant you talk about
sleeping with the boss Sheila and now my
time is up yes this can't be at ratio is
there something wrong with this show
okay and that was 30 something years ago
please you don't look your age is on
sale now